i am passionate about machine learning  but how do i show that to the world  have you considered the google cloud  professional ml engineer certification  it's basically a professional stamp of  approval plus preparing for it will  solidify your understanding of designing  building and productizing your machine  learning models to solve business  challenges using the google cloud ml  tools tell me more about this exam  it's a two hour multiple choice exam and  you can take in a dedicated testing  center or from a remote location via  online proctoring this is great thanks  any advice on where do i start  yep there are tons of training resources  from sample questions to hands-on labs  and on-demand courses just check them  out  wow even better let me get started right  away  you